bonjour à vos bienvenus bienvenue au
sénat bonjour chers collègues sénatrices
et sénateurs je suis je suis très
heureux de vous voir aussi nombreux et
nombreuses avec nous et je l'indiquent
pour les journalistes c'est rare que
pour une mission d'information quasiment
l'ensemble des sénateurs et des
sénatrices et accompagner jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à la conférence de presse les
travaux c'est pour vous le signe que le
sénat a été extrêmement investi sur
cette mission mission d'information qui
a beaucoup travaillé ces trois mois je
le dis pour les journalistes c'est trois
mois de travail intense avec un très
grand nombre d'auditions de
visioconférence pourra aboutir à un
lourd rapport que et qui est à votre
disposition la base sur sur la banque et
un certain nombre de documents plus plus
synthétique à votre disposition je vais
arrêter là mon propos introductif pour
passer très rapidement la parole à
monsieur le rapporteur laurent lafon
président de la commission de la culture
du sénat depuis ensuite nous serons à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions sur le rapporteur jousset de
la parole ils ont six avoue ne dérange
pas je voulais enlever le masque je fais
mon truc je me suis mis un peu de côté
pour respecter ces bons bonjour à tous
et merci à nos collègues c'est vrai que
c'est très agréable de vouziers été
impliqué autant dans cette mission et
que vous soyez jusque présent jusqu'à
cette conférence dé presse merci
beaucoup et puis
alors je vais dire quelques mots et bien
entendu on répondra ensuite à vos
questions parce que j'imagine que vous
en avez c'est difficile d'être
synthétique sur un rapport qui traite de
l'ensemble de la vie étudiante et qui
propose vous le verrez à la fin plus
d'une cinquantaine de propositions je
vais essayer néanmoins de lettres en
m'arrêtant sur les principales
propositions de ce rapport qui a été
voté à l'unanimité
hier en fin d'après-midi par les
sénateurs et sénatrices membres delà de
la mission d'abord étant à l'origine de
la demande de 2 de ceux de cette mission
au niveau du groupe centriste jeu j'aime
à rappeler parce que c'est important
pour la compréhension que en fait cette
cette mission je l'avais demandé il ya
deux ans c'est à dire avant la crise du
coc vide et tout cela si j'insiste là
dessus c'est pour dire que avant même le
coc vide
on savait qu'il y avait des éléments de
de fragilité dans l'organisation autour
des étudiants et qu'il y avait des
phénomènes de précarisation qui touchait
d un certain nombre d'étudiants la crise
du coc vide a été pour l'opinion
publique un révélateur de cette
fragilité qui touche un certain nombre
d'étudiants est bien entendu un
amplificateur des difficultés
rencontrées par ces étudiants quelques
propos introductif avant d'aller dans
les dents dans les propositions
quand on cherche à comprendre pourquoi
on en est arrivé là
qu'est ce qui explique que aujourd'hui
il ya une crise sur l'accompagnement des
étudiants il ya certainement un élément
important a rappelé à savoir que ce qui
a conduit et guider les politiques
publiques en matière d'enseignement
supérieur ces dernières années ça a été
d'abord et avant tout l'accueil d'un
nombre croissant d'étudiants dans les
étapes des différents établissements et
singulièrement dans les universités où
on sait parce que la démographie
étudiante faisait qu'il fallait
accueillir selon les années entre 20 30
mille voire plus étudiants chaque année
la priorité des priorités a été de
pousser les murs de d'accroître le
nombre de places disponibles dans
chacune des filières en tout cas les
plus demandés de faire en sorte
que chacun puisse être inscrits dans
l'enseignement supérieur
cet effort quantitatif c'est très
probablement traduit par une diminution
de la qualité de l'accueil et de la
qualité des politiques d'accompagnement
est aujourd'hui finalement on en paye le
prix
à savoir que ce qui a été fait pour
accroître le nombre d'étudiants s'est
faite au détriment d'un accueil
qualitatif et d'un accompagnement plus
individuelle des étudiants cette forme
en fait de massification de
l'enseignement supérieur maintenant
nécessite d'être rééquilibrée par
quelque chose qui s'accompagnera
beaucoup plus et c'est l'objectif
général derrière l'ensemble de notre
proposition
nos propositions pardon qui ça compte
qui s'apparente beaucoup plus à un
accompagnement individualisé et
personnalisé
en tout cas pour les étudiants qui en
ont besoin
parce que pour nous et je terminerai
enfin non pas tout à fait mais j'insiste
là dessus parce que c'est extrêmement
important
je crois que là aussi dans les dents la
nécessité de rééquilibrer certaines
politiques
il est important de dire qu'il n'ya pas
de réussite académique
un étudiant quel que soit l'étudiant ne
réussit pas ses études quelles que
soient les études si il n'ya pas autour
de lui un environnement qui me facilite
les études dès lors que vous avez un
problème de revenus un problème de
logement un problème d'alimentation voir
un problème de santé évidemment vous
n'êtes pas placer dans de bonnes
conditions pour réussir vos études
cette vérité parce que c'est une vérité
que nous avons tous à l'esprit
malheureusement je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle ait été si présente ses
dernières années dans la définition des
politiques en matière d'enseignement
supérieur
dernière remarque et jeu après je
rentrais plus dans l'est dans le détail
des propositions
une des difficultés auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés comme toute personne
qui s'intéresse à l'enseignement
supérieur c'est d'avoir des données
précises ne serait-ce mais c'est
évidemment extrêmement important quand
on travaille sur ce sujet décidé de
définir quels sont les étudiants en
difficulté
on voit bien que on a une difficulté à
identifier précisément il ya deux types
de population étudiante qui apparaissent
clairement équipes sont apparues
clairement pendant la crise comme étant
les plus touchés c'est les ultramarins
et les étudiants internationaux
mais une fois qu'on a bien identifié ces
deux catégories d'étudiants il y en a
d'autres et les autres c'est beaucoup
plus complexe à identifier j'y
reviendrai notamment à travers des
propositions que nous avons essayé de
former
je vais aborder succinct les
propositions mais pour vous dire que
quand même quand on regarde le panorama
des des politiques d'accompagnement des
étudiants on a un regard assez sévère
sur un certain nombre d'actions qui sont
menées et qui sont encore une fois
insuffisantes pour permettre une
réussite du plus grand nombre
d'étudiants première idée sans doute
phare de notre rapport
c'est d'arriver à replacer ce que nous
avons un peu oublié ces dernières années
a replacé la l'organisation de
l'enseignement supérieur en france dans
une politique d'aménagement du
territoire à travers cela qu'est ce
qu'on veut dire c'est que quand vous
regardez la carte universitaire
singulièrement universitaire elle est
très concentrée autour de grands pôles
universitaires qui ont connu une forte
croissance ces dernières années et
qui se fait d'une certaine manière au
détriment de paul d'université de taille
on va dire familiale ou humaine je ne
sais pas comment on peut le qualifier
mieux répartis sur l'ensemble du
territoire et qui permet une relation de
proximité sur des campus à taille
humaine sur l'ensemble du territoire
national et principalement dans des
villes de taille moyenne
il nous semble que cette réflexion sur
le lien entre l'aménagement du
territoire et organisation du du tissu
universitaire elle a été un peu oublié
et pourtant le présente plein davantage
avantage pour les étudiants eux mêmes
nous traitons ici de des conditions de
réussite de la vie étudiante c'est à
dire les questions de logement des
questions de santé des questions de
revenus des questions de vie sociale et
culturelle vie sportive et évidemment on
sait que quand on est sur des campus de
taille moyenne
ce type de politiques peuvent être plus
facilement appréhender et un
accompagnement plus individus et
individualisé pardon peut-être davantage
appréhender que sur des grandes
universités est évidemment
cette organisation décentralisée
présente un autre avantage et on l'a
bien senti à travers un certain nombre
d'auditions que nous avons réalisés et
puis à travers la connaissance que
chacun des sénateurs membres de la
mission à il ya aussi une aspiration de
la part d'un certain nombre de
collectivités d'accueillir sur leur
territoire des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et d'être un
véritable partenaire de ses
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
nous avons été très impressionnés
favorablement impressionné pendant
l'émission par deux deux sites existants
celui de la rochelle et champollion à
cahors albi pardon à la libye qui du
point de vue de l'accompagnement de
l'étudiant présente des réussites
vraiment très intéressant donc c'est
pour nous un axe majeur de rappeler
d'affirmer cette nécessité de travailler
est sûre sur des universités de taille
humaine et notamment en s'appuyant
j'allais oublier de le dire mais c'est
extrêmement important sur l'organisation
du cursus étudiant qui est comme chacun
le sait marquer par les trois cycles
premier et deuxième cycles
éventuellement troisième cycle et on
peut très bien imaginer assez facilement
que le premier cycle soit fait justement
dans ces établissements à taille humaine
en formule un certain nombre de
propositions pour y revenir à travers
vos questions là dessus de deuxième
grand de sujets que nous avons abordé la
question des revenus
étudiant il a même pas parlé de deux
conditions de vie étudiante sans se
poser la question du rêve du revenu
étudiants je voudrais juste mettre de
fait en parallèle peut être que le
raccourci est rapide mais quoique
les images vues ces derniers mois montre
que c'est pas simplement une
simplification de dire ça l'état
consacre chaque année 5,4 milliards
d'euros à destination des politiques et
des aides aux étudiants s à 16 passait
pas rentrer dans le débat mais en tout
cas c'est un niveau quand même très
significatif et parallèlement vous avez
des étudiants qui sont obligés d'aller
dans les restos du coeur pour pouvoir se
nourrir
donc évidemment les la concomitance de
ces deux réalités ne peut que nous
interroger sur l'efficacité d'un certain
nombre de dispositifs dead existants
d'être financiers existants on pense en
particulier à la question des bourses
sur les critères sociaux qui
représentent trois vieillards 3,8
milliards chaque année on formule un
certain nombre de propositions en la
matière il nous semble qu'une révision
assez général de ses systèmes de bourses
doit être envisagée notamment pour à la
fois mieux les répartir et mieux
identifier les étudiants en difficulté
financière je voudrais juste arrêté sur
deux points là dessus d'abord comme vous
regardez la grille de lecture des
bourses
elle est caractérisée par un grand
nombre de seuils et on sait dans ce type
d'organisation vous avez fait et fait ce
extrêmement marquant c'est à dire vous
passer d'une catégorie à l'autre avec
l'impact extrêmement fort que ça peut
avoir sur le dispositif des aides pour
des augmentations de revenus qui souvent
sont nés ne sont pas corrélées
ça c'est le premier remarques et qui
défavorise les étudiants issus des
classes moyennes et deuxième remarque
nous avons mis en avant et je le dis en
faisant le porte parole mais il
reviendra du président parce qu'il
insiste beaucoup là dessus sur la notion
de reste à charge
une des préoccupations de la mission et
a été de disais tout à l'heure
d'identifier les étudiants dans le
besoin
quels sont ceux qui sont le plus dans la
difficulté et avons mis en avant cette
idée de calculer un reste à charge c'est
à dire quand vous prenez les revenus les
ressources de l'étudiant et puis les
principales dépenses en particulier le
logement parce qu'on sait que c'est un
des éléments selon la localisation des
lieux d'études et d'une résidence qui
peut avoir le plus d'impact sur le
budget quel est le reste à charge de
l'étudiant et est ce que en fonction de
ce reste à charge une aide plus
spécifique doit être mise en place
cette notion de reste à charge n'existe
pas jusqu'à présent il nous paraît
extrêmement important dernière remarque
sur le système dead on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya un problème de un déficit de
connaissances des étudiants sur les
aides que ce soit les aides en
provenance de l'état que ce soit les
aides en provenance des collectivités où
que ce soit aussi les aides en
provenance des établissements quand il
en existe et on préconise la mise en
place d'un guichet unique avec des
procédures de simplification pour
faciliter l'accès des dispositifs à
l'ensemble des étudiants un mot on y
reviendra peut-être avec à travers vos
questions nous sommes assez réservé
assez prudent sur le système d'emprunt
on sait que
il peut y avoir une tentation de dire
pour financer non seulement les études
mais tout ce qui participe aux études à
la vie étudiante
un recours à l'emprunt la mission est
assez prudente sur le recours à
l'emprunt
quelques mots sur sur le logement qui
est évidemment un des aspects importants
de la vie étudiante
on voit bien que j'allais dire de
gouvernement au gouvernement on bute sur
cette question du logement étudiant et
la difficulté de construire un nombre
suffisant de logements étudiants ont
évalué le déficit à peu près de cent
cinquante mille logements alors
évidemment réparties de façon
inéquitable sur le territoire il ya des
zones où les besoins sont plus
importants territoire national que
d'autres néanmoins on voit bien que on
n'arrive pas à combler ce déficit est le
dernier plan du gouvernement montre bien
qu on est loin des objectifs annoncés en
réalisation nous préconisons sur les
politiques de construction de logements
étudiants de fonctionner à partir
d'objectifs territorialisés l'idée est
de définir en partenariat avec les
collectivités pour lequel sans les
collectivités ne peut pas y avoir des
efforts en matière de construction de
logements étudiants donc ça doit être
fait bien sûr un partenariat avec l est
et en particulier bien sûr les communes
ou les intercommunalités de définir
quelles peuvent être les objectifs en
fonction des besoins
les objectifs de construction de
logements étudiants dans chacun des
secteurs géographiques de même
évidemment tout un tas de réflexion sur
la question du logement étudiant mais il
ya les autres modes de logement
d'essayer de de faciliter l'accès des
autres modes de logement pour pour pour
les étudiants n'y reviendra peut-être à
travers vos vos questions si vous me
permettez monsieur président encore deux
trois éléments désolé d'être pas de
balayer peut-être un peu rapidement mais
le sujet malheureusement et à ses divers
sur les questions de santé dont on a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers mois et la
crise a montré
je pense que tout le monde est d'accord
sur le fait que l'organisation la
l'identification des besoins de santé
des étudiants est l'organisation des
systèmes de santé au tour des étudiants
étaient sans doute et est insuffisant on
en a beaucoup parlé à travers des à
travers les le soutien psychologique et
l'aide psychologique avec les mesures
notamment prise par le par le
gouvernement pour accroître le nombre de
psychologues intervenant auprès des
jeunes vous savez les 80 postes créés
avant ses 80 postes il y avait eu tp
pour 30 me labi pour trente mille
étudiants bon on voit bien quand on
regarde l'organisation que on est sur
une organisation qui ne permet pas de
couvrir de manière satisfaisante les
besoins en termes de santé 100 vous
abreuver de chiffres juste celui là
seulement un quart des étudiants auront
fréquenté un service ait su mais mbps un
service médical de prévention dans les
établissements pendant leur cursus à
dire que les trois-quarts échappe
pendant tout le cursus des repas pendant
une année mais pendant tout le cursus et
chapin
à ces services de médecine mise en place
dans les établissements
quand on regarde juste les bas pu vous
savez les organisations existantes pour
le le soin psychologique
évidemment nous avons été frappés par le
faible nombre de bas puis il en existe
18 sur le territoire national et des
agglomérations aussi importante que
toulouse bordeaux lyon ou nantes n'ont
pas de papiers sur leur territoire alors
il est évident que là dessus il ya un
effort à faire il ya aussi tout un
travail j'y reviendrai peut-être à
travers vos questions à faire en termes
de réseaux de 2,2 de santé autour des
étudiants qui implique certes les
structures dédiées aux étudiants celle
que je viens de citer mais aussi les
autres organisations hospitalières ou
médecine de ville
sur la question du chèque du chèque si
mis en place par le gouvernement pendant
la crise nous nous préconisons que cette
mesure soit maintenue parce que
évidemment les besoins sont sont sont
encore très présents je passe sur un
autre sujet mais qui est un sujet
important sur la question des du travail
rémunéré pour les étudiants la question
de ce qu'on appelle les petits jobs sur
bon de manière un peu rapide évidemment
il ne s'agit pas de remettre en cause
l'existence de deux des travail rémunéré
pour les les étudiants on sait que dans
tout un tas de situations
ça peut être quelque chose de positif
par rapport à la poursuite des études
d'avoir un pied dans les études et un
pied dans une réalité économique
et puis ça a été complètement de revenus
qui sont tout à fait légitimes
en revanche on attire évidemment
l'attention et une vigilance quand le
travail rémunéré met en difficulté la
poursuite des études
on sait que en moyenne il ya 40% enfin
il ya 40% des étudiants qui ont un job
étudiant au moins qu'ils déclarent et
que parmi les étudiants 8 % ont une
activité s'avère quasiment un sur dix on
va dire ont une activité concurrente ou
30 très concurrentes pardon de leurs
études
c'est à dire un temps consacré à
l'activité rémunérée supérieure à plus
de la moitié de sa supérieure à 1
mi-temps de leur temps de travail global
et on sait que c'est un élément
déclencheur pour une mise en difficulté
si on peut dire ainsi de 2 du parcours
universitaire quand eux tout à l'heure
en introduction je vous disais que la
philosophie de la mission était de
travailler davantage sur un suivi
personnalisé des étudiants et un
accompagnement des étudiants
typiquement il devrait y avoir des
effets des seuils d'alerté
justement compte l'importance du travail
rémunéré fait que l'étudiant est mise en
difficulté dans sa poursuite d'études un
suivi personnalisé de l'étudiant devrait
être instaurée permettant d'abord de
voir qu'elle est quels sont les
aménagements possibles et aussi de quais
dans quelle manière éventuellement des
aides financières supplémentaires
doivent être mobilisées pour permettre à
l'étudiant de se consacrer d'abord à la
réussite de de ces études nous sommes un
certain nombre de propositions sur
l'emploi étudiant
mais là aussi je passe très rapidement
pour faciliter l'emploi étudiants dans
les universités
puisqu'il ya un certain nombre de
blocages notamment à travers le plafond
d'emplois qui fait que des tâches qui
pourraient être affectées qui pourraient
être réalisés par des étudiants des
tâches rémunérées qui pourraient être
réalisés par des étudiants sont
difficilement mobilisables pour
l'instant et il ya des propositions que
nous formulons dans ce sens voilà
monsieur le président je sais pas si
j'ai certainement oublier des choses
j'en suis désolé mais l'idée était de
balayer rapidement le des quelques
propositions pour pouvoir avoir un
échange bien sûr avec eux merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur
je vous propose de distribuer la parole
dans le sens de la lecture et de
commencer par vous madame si vous le
souhaitez est-ce que vous souhaitez j'ai
plaisir à commencer par par vous en vous
donnant la parole merci à lisbourg y ait
là je suis journaliste a à f
vous parliez d'une éventuelle refonte du
système de bourse
j'aimerais connaître votre avis sur est
du reste à charge sur la question des
profils particuliers de l'étudiant et
comment est ce que dans le cas d'une
éventuelle réforme on pourrait prendre
en compte de manière plus satisfaisante
les revenus les ressources réelles des
étudiants qui ne sont pas
systématiquement le reflet des revenus
de leurs parents
donc ça ce serait une première question
ensuite sur la question sur la question
des services de santé universitaire
actuellement il ya l'inspection générale
qui se penche sur sur le sujet il ya la
question éventuelle de faire basculer ce
type de service dans les crous c'est des
questions qu'on entend qu'est-ce que
quelle est votre position là dessus
et enfin pour limiter
enfin je reprendrai peut-être la parole
après mais sur la question du logement
des crous comment faciliter l'accès au
foncier est ce qu'on peut réfléchir à
introduire logements étudiants à
tarification sociale dans
la loi sru pendant les obligations des
communes
est ce que vous avez des pistes pour
faciliter l'accès au foncier je vous
remercie
je vais prendre d'autres questions comme
ça ça permettra une réponse plus plus
synthétique monsieur je vous en prie
allez-y merci martin le sénéchal
journalistes pour news tank
j'avais quatre questions ça vous va
merci vous avez parlé d'une crise de
l'accompagnement et d'un manque de
personnalisation des parcours il me
semble c'était pourtant l'objectif
fondamental de la loi aux airs de 2018
s est ce à dire que cette loi était un
échec et n'a pas donné les les
conséquences quelles qu'elles le
souhaitaient vous avez parlé d'un
maillage renforcée des établissements à
taille humaine
on sait qu'actuellement c'est sur ces
territoires qui le manque aussi des
infrastructures de vie étudiantes
notamment restauration universitaire ça
fait l'objet d'une proposition au sénat
et à l'assemblée
donc oui de toutes ces infrastructures
et avec l'idée aussi d'un premier cycle
renforcer sur ces structures est ce que
c'est pas faire naître un système
universitaire à deux vitesses est ce que
vous avez eu des retours du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation sur les différentes
propositions formulées vendredi la
ministre interviendra pour présenter son
plan pour la rentrée ce que vous avez
des attentes sur ce plan puisque le
rapport de françoise moulin civil par
récemment recoupent pas mal de vos
propositions notamment pérennisation de
certains dispositifs de la crise et
enfin au niveau financier
beaucoup de mesures qui n'est pas eu le
temps encore de tout regarder
à combien vous chiffrer toutes ces
mesures et est-ce qu'il est temps comme
avec la recherche de faire une loi de
programmation de l'enseignement
supérieur merci
le rapporteur vous laisse la parole
alors quelques éléments de réponse mais
ce président et les autres sénateurs
membres de la mission s'ils veulent
intervenir qu ils ne s'en privent pas
bon c'est sûr leur fondue du système de
bourse sur les profils particuliers
c'est nous c'est pour ça qu'on met en
avant cette notion de notion de reste à
charge c'est parce que effectivement il
ya un problème d'identification aider
des étudiants le plus sens dans les
besoins dans la difficulté et que on le
sait il ya des éléments comme le
logement évidemment mais aussi l'appui
ou pas de la famille dans la lah puyehue
l'appui réelle ou pas de la famille dans
la dans le pour les études qui sont des
éléments importants c'est pour ça que
nos propositions il ya deux éléments qui
peuvent répondre nous semble-t-il c'est
un la notion de reste à charge a
vraiment définir à la fin qu'est ce qui
reste à l'étudiant est ce qu'il est dans
une situation où il était en difficulté
financière ou pas et deuxièmement un
accompagnement par l'établissement
lui-même parce que cette question
financière elle est aussi à prendre en
compte par rapport à la conduite de son
parcours universitaire dans quelle
mesure la charge de travail et/ou au
travail rémunéré dans quelle mesure les
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent sur le
plan de sa vie courante vont impacter ou
pas son parcours est du coup comment on
a juste ça et ça ça ne peut être fait
pour ça qu'on insiste beaucoup sur cette
notion de d'individualisation et
d'accompagnement individuel sur 7/7 ça
ne peut être fait qu'au niveau de
l'établissement mais lui-même
je pars si j'ai répondu suffisamment
mais sur le
sur la question de des services de santé
et bex qu'une demande dans les crous n'a
pas semblé que c'était une préoccupation
de demandes majeures notamment des
acteurs de santé
aucun ne l'a formulée en tant qu' en
tant que tel on a organisé ces mêmes
d'ailleurs une table ronde avec quelques
acteurs de santé
c'est pas
si c'est pas le besoin le plus évident
enfin le plus criant qui est venu à
l'esprit
je pense que c'est il ya certainement
une réflexion à renforcer certains
moyens et certainement une réflexion sur
sas est venu à plusieurs reprises sur
structurer un système de santé autour
des étudiants en impliquant les autres
acteurs du système de santé je parlais
des hôpitaux et de la médecine de ville
qui sont à notre avis plus important est
prioritaire que cela sur la question du
logement vous parlez de de faciliter
l'accès au foncier ce qui est une vraie
problématique vous avez tout à fait
raison quand on sait que ça peut d'abord
il peut y avoir du foncier existant et
parfois du foncier qui est bloqué c'est
pour ça que on a introduit cette notion
de territorialisation qui suppose parce
que cet objectif territorialisée doit
pas être imposée aux collectivités mais
il doit être discutée avec les
collectivités de voir comment
concrètement telle ou telle commune
telles ou telles que pci peut remplir un
objectif de construction de deux
logements étudiants
c'est là dessus qu'on peut
éventuellement quand la situation de
blocage de foncier sont du plus à des
comment dirais-je à des comportements
prudentielles qu'à des problèmes de
propriété
c'est comme ça notre avis qu'on peut
qu'on peut avancer c'est dans un
dialogue
entre état et collectivités sur des
objectifs partagés
vous disiez par rapport à la loi sru le
logement étudiant peut rentrer en compte
un logement social étudiant rentre en
compte dans le calcul de la loi sru donc
s'il n'y a pas une difficulté à ce
niveau là je fais une petite parenthèse
j'ai oublié de le dire tout à l'heure
mais c'est important
nous nous engageons dans quelques heures
le débat sur la loi
3ds vous savez sur la loi de
décentralisation il n'ya rien seul
enseignement supérieur
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui est à
noter que nous avons noté et quand on
insiste sur l'idée de dire il faut
appliquer les collectivités dans
l'enseignement supérieur parce qu'elles
sont demandeuses un certain nombre sont
demandeuses
on voit bien que c'est pas actuellement
en tout cas l'état d'esprit sur sur
monsieur vous posiez la question de sur
la loi elle est re et le fait qu' il y
avait déjà cessé notion d'accompagnement
qui apparaissait dans la loi elle est re
est ce qu'on peut en déduire que la loi
lru est un échec
j'irai pas jusque là je dois j'ai oublié
de le dire et votre question il fait
penser
parallèlement à notre mission la
commission et culture éducation
communication du sénat avait confié une
mission à deux rapporteurs qui sont ici
parce qu'ils sont également membres de
la mission
céline boulay espejo nier et et bernard
fialaire sur la cv oc qui était un des
dispositifs en tout cas un dispositif
financier pour pour financer un certain
nombre de dispositifs liés à la vie
étudiante
je laisserai s'exprimer bien sûr s'ils
le souhaitent mais j'allais dire
heureusement qui a eu la cec ces
derniers mois puisque de mémoire vont
manger si je me trompe mais il ya 230
millions qui ont été affectés sur les
deux dernières années par la cec aux
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et on l'a vu à travers les visites de
terrain que nous avons organisé ça a été
utile il ya un vrai enjeu on y reviendra
nôtres le rapporteur des crédits
budgétaires il sera il y est déjà très
attentif mais vous savez que cette cdc
plafonné à 140 millions et je crois que
nous sommes à 139 millions cette année
donc
on va butter si ce n'est déjà fait
rapidement sur le plafond il faudra
faire sauter le plafond parce qu'il ya
aucune raison que cet argent ne
reviennent pas aux établissements
d'enseignement supérieur après voilà
plus spécifiquement pour la loi l
heureux après c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
pour nous l'essentiel des efforts faits
ces dernières années on était sûr de
l'accueil quantitatif et pas assez
qualitatif
donc ça répond en partie à vous à votre
question sur les les établissements à
taille humaine alors sur la question de
la restauration universitaire vous avez
tout à fait raison
effectivement dans les dans les villes
moyennes le crous et très organisés
autour des grands pôles universitaires
et on le voit bien dans les villes
moyennes il ya des il ya des trous dans
la raquette ou des insuffisances de de
couverture il ya aussi des solutions qui
ne sont pas assez mobilisé des
partenariats qui peuvent exister
notamment avec les collectivités locales
pour que les étudiants dans ces villes
est accès à des systèmes de restauration
collective à des prix évidemment qui
sont ceux du crous et on préconise je
crois même que le rapporteur va déposer
enfin a déposé un amendement dans trois
des leurs à porter et président déposé
un amendement dans 3ds sur ce sujet là
donc il ya possibilité on a voté ici au
sénat il ya quelques jours une ppl sur
le ticket restaurant justement dans dans
ces zones la terre que vous avez raison
sur le constat mais c'est pas
rédhibitoire il ya des solutions
possibles qui nous peuvent être favoris
est ce qu'un système à deux vitesses
est-ce que ça introduirait un système à
devise est ce qu'il ya déjà un système à
deux vitesses pour là où ça existe
est-ce que ça si on développe et
introduire un système à deux vitesses
je ne sais pas mais sa part du postulat
de dire qu'on réussit plus ces études
ont ainsi mieux ses études
quand on est dans des grands pôles
universitaires que quand on est dans des
ddd
paul plus plus restreint plus on partage
pas ce postulat donc on forme une pas la
question dans cette manière parce que et
les chiffres d'ailleurs c'est un point
qu'on a vérifié les chiffres en terme de
réussite cas au premier cycle montre
qu'il n'y a pas de
deux distinctions à opérer selon que
vous avez fait je sais pas vous études à
la sorbonne ou que vous avez fait vos
études
l'institut champollion albi trompe pas
c'est précis en revanche ce qui est
important mais on a moins d'inquiétude
là-dessus
ces dernières années c'est que l'accès
au master d'introduire ce pas une
distorsion selon que vous avez fait vos
études à la sorbonne ou agents position
pour reprendre mon exemple mais c'est un
autre sujet mais c'est un sujet connexe
mais on est plutôt on va dire plutôt
rassurés sur ce plan là dessus bon
est-ce que quelle a été la réaction de
la ministre à nos propositions il n'a
pas encore eu parce que c'est vous qui
en avait la primeur
tant qu'il n'a pas encore officiellement
présenté à la ministre on a auditionné
la ministre il ya quelques jours
bon écoute et on va attendre les
propositions sur son plan de rentrer bon
on a entendu des déclarations du
président de la république et quelques
semaines annonçant une réforme des
des bourses on attend aussi les
propositions donc nous serons attentifs
ce qui peut être annoncé dans les
semaines à venir où on s'inscrit d'ores
et déjà dans le débat et qui on a des
propositions à travers notre rapport et
puis ça sera bien sûr d'un dialogue qu
on confrontera à la fois nos
propositions et celles du gouvernement
alors sur le coût des mesures bon on n'a
pas chiffrées très honnêtement on n'a
pas chiffré nos mesures je suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit très coûteuse en revanche
voudrais attirer votre attention sur un
point qui me paraît important et j'ai
oublié de le dire en introduction
tout à l'heure je vous disais que la
démographie étudiante vous le savez tous
que si vous suivez ces questions nous
étions nous sommes encore avons connue
et nous sommes encore dans une
croissance démographique étudiante avec
en moyenne on va dire 25 à 30 mille
étudiants nous on sait tout le monde
sait que cette croissance
elle n'est pas éternelle famille un
moment elle se elle va se stabiliser
elle va même décroître c'est le principe
même des des cycles démographique
difficile de savoir quand est-ce parce
que les données sont un peu imprécis ce
sujet est ce que c'est en 2023 2025 en
tout cas sa brève échéance
un des enjeux principaux et c'est pour
ça que cette phase rapport est important
notamment dans la perspective des débats
budgétaires
les lois de finances c'est que on veut
absolument pérenniser les dispositifs
des moyens existants actuellement forme
de la deûle et de les maintenir
on sait que la tentation sera grande
notamment à bercy de dire il ya moins
d'étudiants on va diminuer certains
dispositifs existants au contraire il va
falloir maintenir à défaut d accroître
son peu les à croître tant mieux pour
des raisons budgétaires mais si le
contexte ne s'y prête pas de les
maintenir pour pouvoir faire en sorte
que le montant moyen par étudiant soit
en augmentation et
notamment pour ce qui est des bourses
quand on dit qu'il faut travailler sur
une révision assez générales du système
de bourses et une réallocation à
destination des étudiants qui en ont le
plus besoin c'est bien sûr par un
maintien de et puis par ailleurs c'est
important aussi l'implication entre
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
et collectivités on le sait ya des
collectivités qui sont prêtes à
accompagner leurs établissements que ce
soit sur le plan d'un certain nombre de
politiques d'accompagnement sur le
logement sur la restauration jeu c'était
tout à l'heure où ceux des dispositifs
sociaux mais y compris sur sur
l'entretien des bâtiments
bon alors on essaye depuis quelques
semaines en vain mais enfin bon un jour
ça passera de créer d'autoriser la
création des spl société publique locale
dans lequel collectivités et
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
puis son ensemble gérer et entretenir
des parcs de bâtiments mais si on le
suicide c'est pas pour l'imposer aux
collectivités mais c'est parce qu'on
sait que certaines collectivités sont
demandeuses
dans ces cas là évidemment du coup il ya
eu aussi des moyens financiers qu'elles
pourront apporter
merci monsieur le rapporteur je veux
juste ajouter un mot en tant que
président pour pour vous dire que les
les conclusions les préconisations de ce
rapport ont fait l'objet d'un très fort
consensus de notre commission du début
de la mission de la formation il ya
trois mois jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et que à titre personnel je n'aurais pas
voté un rapport qui préconise
l'instauration d'un système
universitaire à deux vitesses pour
reprendre l'exemple d'albi il n'ya pas
albi qui est en pro d2 et toulouse en
top 14
la ja il ya un seul il ya un seul
championnat dont l'objectif est de
permettre à tous les étudiants quel
qu'il soit d'accéder au service public
de l'enseignement supérieur
et de les accompagner le plus haut
possible dans leur cursus
ce que ce que nous a dit la présidente
de l'institut universitaire champollion
à albi c'est que elle accueillait des
étudiants qui sent son université
n'aurait jamais eu l'idée de frapper à
la porte de toulouse parce que pour eux
c'est la grande ville c'est la métropole
c'est beaucoup trop beaucoup trop loin
et parmi ces étudiants et il y en a qui
a ensuite fondé parcours universitaire
tout à fait exceptionnelle ailleurs et
la conscience que albi arrive à assurer
la totalité du premier cycle que
contrairement à toulouse et ne pourra
pas offrir des cursus dans tous les
domaines mais en revanche elle considère
que sur certaines niches pédagogique
albi peut parfaitement être à un niveau
national élevés sur des choses très
déterminé donc ce qu'il faut jouer c'est
la complémentarité entre les différents
systèmes
ce que ce conte ce qu'on souhaitait dire
et je me permets une formule un peu un
peu un peu facile c'est que il faut il
faut penser plus le local est un peu
moins globale c'est à dire oublier un
petit peu les classements internationaux
dont un certain classement promu en
chine pour se réinvestir sur les enjeux
locaux
ça fait sans doute trop longtemps qu' on
ne pense l'enseignement supérieur
français que dans un système où faudrait
porter les cinq meilleures universités
françaises un sommet reconnu
internationalement il faut comme le
disait très justement le rapporteur
repenser l'université dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du territoire en
n'oubliant pas et c'est important parce
que ça fait plusieurs fois que les
collectivités elles nous le disent
qu'elles ont un intérêt immense dans
leurs relations avec les universités à
la fois pour aider leurs étudiants mais
aussi parce qu'elle trouve dans les
universités des compétences qu'elles ont
besoin pour porter leurs politiques
publiques et c'est quelque chose qu'on a
oublié cette
l'interaction forte merci je peux je
peux continuer à donner la parole aux
journalistes
allez-y bonjour naim sacrée d'humanité
j'avais deux questions brûlent armand
sur les profils des personnes et des
associations organisations vous avez
rencontré que quelles sont elles et est
ce que la question du salaire ou dure
aux deux étudiants qui est l'une des
revendications de nombre d'organisations
de jeunesse a été posée et qu'elle est
quelle est votre réflexion là dessus
merci je vais passer la parole à marie
christine cordier du journal les échos
qu'étant en visioconférence est-ce que
vous m'entendez très bien allez-y madame
c'est parfait ça fonctionne super bien
et je voudrais revenir sur quelque chose
qui a été évoqué à la fois par laurent
d'asthme et un monsieur ozu vias
c'est sur le volet aménagement du
territoire ch et l'organisation des
grands pôles universitaires
est ce que c'est ce que vous préconisez
et par un peu illusoire avec la crise et
développement du numérique qui
conduisent de plus en plus
d'établissements à partager un bureau de
la scolarité à avoir un système de
gestion de salles commun à plusieurs
écoles ou plusieurs établissements et et
tout ça j'allais dire aliments justement
le fait d'être avec d'autres sur un même
site
physiquement et donc alimente les gros
paul j'ai en tête ce qui s'est passé à
cholet où des établissements ont quitté
cholet pour rejoindre angers par exemple
donc est ce que malgré vos
préconisations
il n'y a pas quelque chose une sorte de
contre vague j'allais dire avec la crise
et les ducaux vidé et donc le
développement de deux numérique de
toutes les prédations et tout ce qui va
avec qui va à l'encontre de cet
aménagement du territoire et donc qui
renforce
de fait la constitution des grands pôles
voilà
je prendre encore une question peut-être
allez-y monsieur non oui est ce que vous
auriez une question à poser
non est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
journalistes qui veulent poser des
questions alesina oui c'est deux petites
questions
j'ai vu que vous proposiez de pérenniser
le ticket ru à 1 euro mais pourquoi
seulement pour les étudiants boursiers
alors que avant la crise c'était un des
riffs qui était universel au niveau des
crous et aussi j'ai compris que vous
vouliez un portail et un guichet unique
sous forme de portail pour avoir accès à
ces aides est ce que finalement ça
n'existe pas déjà à travers la
plateforme un jeune une solution où on a
un petit questionnaire est est ce que il
n'ya pas des solutions humaines aussi à
aller chercher en termes de recrutement
d'assistants d'assistantes sociales dans
les universités et dans les crous et
peut-être en fait ils troisième question
j'ai compris que vous vouliez que les
collectivités puissent jouer un rôle
plus important notamment dans le
logement
on voit qu'il ya un problème de
lisibilité des aides parce qu'il ya
différents acteurs à différentes
échelles qui sont qui sont qui sont dans
dans le milieu de la vie étudiante est
ce que ça va pas rajouter de la
complexité dans l'accès au logement
étudiant
là où le crous étaient identifiés comme
l'acteur principal pour trouver une
chambre en cité u
pour pour vous montrer que le travail
des équipes dans cette mission n'est pas
un vain mot
j'ai envie de demander à sonia de la
provôté de répondre à la question de
madame corbier sur les petits pôles
universitaires les grands pôles la
métropolisation parce que je sais
qu'elle a d'excellentes idées et puis
elle habite quand et quand c'est
vraiment un très bon exemple de
l'université à taille moyenne où il ya
un accompagnement juste avant lui donner
la parole moi j'ai moi j'ai enseigné à
nanterre université nanterre université
de pas rien et ça fait quelques temps et
je me souviens avoir toujours dit à mes
étudiants qu'est ce que vous faites en
région parisienne
qu'est ce que vous faites là regardez
les moyens matériels dont vous disposez
regarder le taux d'encadrement dont vous
disposez sincèrement vous seriez
beaucoup mieux à la rochelle à caen etc
et
je suis désolé mais ce constat il n'a
pas changé bien au contraire
bien au contraire ce que ce que
j'aimerais dire parce que ça ne se sait
pas mais le taux de réussite à
l'institut universelle en po lyon d'albi
c'est parmi les cinq meilleurs de france
donc si on considère aujourd'hui que ce
qui fait une bonne université
c'est une université qui qui va ce qui
vous accompagnent dans un parcours de
réussite là le classement devrait donner
une note exceptionnelle à albi voilà
j'en finis la saunière tu peux peut-être
répondre merci beaucoup c'est tout à
fait le bon oui en fait là dans les
auditions on a été quand même mis en
évidence l'évolution des méthodes
d'enseignement parce que ce que nous
traversons
à la fois mis en lumière l'intérêt de
et la qualité potentielle et réelle de
l'enseignement distanti elle a mis en
lumière le fait qu'un certain type
d'enseignement en présentiel n'avait pas
forcément une valeur ajoutée dans
l'accompagnement des étudiants et
notamment les enseignements en et
mystique la très grand effectif où
l'interaction individuelles étaient
plutôt amoindri et surtout une demande
importante et croissante et notamment
c'est ce qui est vraiment repris dans le
rapport et qui a été appuyé par le
rapporteur cette notion de
l'accompagnement individualisé qui est
valable autant pour la vie la vie
étudiante que pour la qualité de
l'enseignement et notamment beaucoup
d'interlocuteurs ont mis en valeur les
enseignements dirigé les travaux dirigés
la nécessité finalement que de
démultiplier que ces opportunités de
relations ultra qualitative entre
l'enseignant et des besoins de
l'étudiant
ce qui interpelle sur la façon dont on
doit désormais concevoir les
enseignements cette part du distant ciel
du présentiel et je crois que si on
s'est vraiment bien relevés dans le
rapport
si ici on a affaire un bilan de tout ça
c'est qu'il faut laisser une place aux
distances yale à l'enseignement
numérique dans sa part franchement
qualitative parce que là où ça a été
reçue dans les réussi dans les
établissements et on l'a bien vu
clairement c'est une dimension
importante et pour le coup ça laisse
justement une grande opportunité aussi
te déconcentrer et aussi qu'ils sont pas
les titres metropolit a aidé les grands
sites universitaires
parce que ça veut dire que dans des
sites des concentrés de plus petite
taille
certes on n'a pas accès au grand amphi
mais on n'y a accès autrement assez
court là et pour le coup on a accès plus
facilement à l'enseignement
individualisé aux enseignements dirigés
aux travaux dirigés qui qui sont plus en
proximité de chez soi donc plus
confortable aussi pour l'étudiant et
dans sa disponibilité personnelle
pour pour acquérir des compétences et
donc c'est vrai que cette politique
décide déconcentré avait été une
possible politiques mises en oeuvre il
ya de nombreuses années
qui pour des raisons budgétaires depuis
un certain nombre d'années avait
tendance à considérer que non il fallait
tout centraliser aussi pour des raisons
de visibilité internationale des sites
où sont concentrés les étudiants le
nombre d'étudiants les chercheurs les
enseignants et les publications est tous
allés dans le même sens et qu'en réalité
ce qu'on vient de traverser montre qu'on
peut faire aussi ça en n'étant pas
forcément sur place et avec probablement
une plus grande qualité parce que plus
d'accompagnement personnalité et
personnaliser et de capacité pour
l'étudiant lui-même à pouvoir se
réaliser
plus personnellement dans ce qu'il fait
merci sonia monsieur le rapporteur et
après je demanderai la christian
d'ajouter un point aussi sur la porte à
ces quelques éléments de réponse dans la
question aux sources qui restaurent eu
un euro alors effectivement on préconise
un maintien pur pour les étudiants
boursiers
pourquoi pas pour l'ensemble des
étudiants pour parce que c'est pas
forcément nécessaire pour l'ensemble des
étudiants et puis surtout il y ait une
dimension financière et budgétaire
auxquels on ne peut pas échapper par
rapport aux coussins on a évidemment
auditionné la présidente du cnous et
travaillé avec plusieurs coups dans le
cadre de cette mission
la mesure a un impact elle était
nécessaire bien entendu mais en période
de crise mais elle a un impact financier
réel sur les équilibres financiers des
crous et donc c'était une mesure
d'exception
et on va entrer on l'espère tous dans un
rythme plus normal donc elle nous paraît
être intéressant par rapport est d'être
prolongé par rapport aux étudiants
boursiers mais pas forcément généralisée
quand on sort de la période
exceptionnelle du duc o vite par rapport
au logement
le rôle du crous certes le crous et
l'acteur principal et doit le rester il
n'y a pas de d'ambiguïté là dessus mais
en revanche est peut-être que la
meilleure réponse est dans la situation
actuelle c'est quand je vous disais que
il manque deux cent cinquante mille
logements bien dire qu'on n'a pas
répondu dans l'organisation actuelle à
tous les besoins donc il ya nécessité
aussi de de ne pas se cantonner à un
seul acteur d'accompagner cet acteur et
un bon travail mais de ne pas se limiter
à un seul acteur et d'essayer de
multiplier les ce qui compte c'est
d'arriver à sortir c'est ces logements
est aussi d'avoir une information parce
que je crois que c'était le sens de
votre question la question c'est comment
l'étudiant a accès à l'information c'est
là où c'est des notions de guichet
unique
on a oublié de le dire mais c'est
important parce que plusieurs sénateurs
insistent là-dessus et à juste titre
c'est qu'il ya nécessité de profiter
entre guillemets je trouve pas le bon
terme et vous m'en excuserez de la phase
d'inscription et d'accueil ou
un certain nombre d'informations
essentielles pour l'accompagnement de
l'étudiant dans son parcours universités
peuvent universitaire donc peuvent être
donnés et il ya eu quelques expériences
on en a vu qui sont tout à fait positive
en la matière ou soit lors de
l'inscription soit lors des premières
journées d'arriver à l'université il ya
un temps d'information qui est organisé
et c'est vrai que c'est aussi par ces
temps là que ce type d'information peut
être peut être établie je voudrais citer
pardon mais sur cette question dans
l'ancrage territorial
parce que ce c'est le président
rappelait qu parfois son expérience
personnelle est toujours intéressante
dans le sens paris province
nous avons ici aussi alors bon et on
peut pas se généraliser une expérience
un car bien entendu mais c'est aussi des
sources d'inspiration on a auditionné
l'université une université parisienne
qui est sur un cursus d'ortho petit qui
envoyait pour les stages avec un
partenariat avec les collectivités en
l'occurrence leurs étudiants à nevers ce
qui correspondant plus à la lan et
soeurs besoins de couverture médicale
dans un certain nombre de zones et on
voit parce que maintenant c'est un
partenariat qui s'inscrit dans le temps
que c'est aussi une vraie réussite donc
on peut trouver de nombreux exemples de
2,2 de réussite
tout à l'heure vous parler jusque usées
moi je
je reviens un peu en arrière mais parler
de cité à deux vitesses ça peut être
aussi universités de province peuvent
être en avance sur plein de sujets ont
parlé de la rochelle parce que c'est un
bel exemple de réussite
j'ai beaucoup insisté sur les premiers
cycles c'est vrai mais il ya aussi des
seconds cycles et des troisièmes cycles
l'université de la rochelle
alors évidemment chaque territoire a ses
spécificités ses atouts ses
caractéristiques à des masters de
premier plan en matière de sciences de
l'environnement pour tout ce qui est
géographie appliquée à la gestion des
littoraux ou en matière de 2
de tourisme et d'ingénierie littoral là
on voit bien qu'il ya un espèce de spots
is et le mot cluster ça ça va faire peur
à tout le monde mais deux phénomènes
oui c'est ça deux phénomènes qui joue
très positivement entre l'établissement
d'enseignement supérieur là où les
collectivités et puis le tissu
d'entreprises qui peut permettre de
créer une vraie vraie cluster de
formation et d'emploi qu'ils soient très
favorables aux étudiants questions
renonce à rasic était sénateur de la
haute vienne donc qui connaît bien le
cas d'université de seconde zone les
molles c'est bon oui et j'apporterai un
complément hambourg nation tout d'abord
c'est le président et le rapporteur de
la qualité des à la fois des propos et
du travail que vous avez conduit on
parle terre était réalisation mais
attention il y à gérer différentes
situations on n'évoque que l'institut
champollion d'albi l'inertie de la
rochelle se sont désistés mission de
plein exercice autonome budgétairement
haineux etc
mais on a aussi beaucoup d'universités
qui ont délocalisé essentiellement des
formations de premier cycle ou des
technologiques ou généraliste j'étais
effectivement directeur de l'iut dans
l'université de limoges mais j'avais six
sites différents et avec et le
rapporteur vous l'avez évoqué quelques
difficultés quant au montage et au
soutien des collectivités territoriales
dans lesquels avec lesquels nous étions
partenaires notamment eu égard aux
compétences et vous l'avez rappelé la
loi 3ds n'a bords de nive problèmes des
étudiants ni le problème
l'enseignement supérieur or tout ce que
nous évoquons ce final ça devienne
histoire de moyens souvent et de
capacités on les régions on sait on
connaît leurs compétences pour
accompagner
il ya un petit trou à raquettes puisque
ces villes où métropole mais les agglos
n'ont pas la compétence enseignement
supérieur donc l'architecturé complexe
et il est nécessaire de territorialiser
mais je crois qu'il faudra aussi que
qu'on aille plus loin dans
l'accompagnement et dans les outils
qu'on pourrait donner à ces territoires
pour justement porté porté les
formations et un autre petit point que
vous avez évoqué effectivement le
prochain la prochaine annonce de la
ministre
j'espère que ça ne sera pas que les
annonces poste convient
j'espère qu'on va rentrer dans le post
co vide qu'on n'aura pas de quatrième
vague ce qui serait une catastrophe
mais vous l'avez rappelé entrepôt
préliminaire vous aviez interrogée enfin
vous aviez souhaité cette mission avant
le kovic crois que le problème irlandais
rocco vite donc il ne faudrait pas que
les réponses apportées dans les
prochaines semaines ne soient que des
réponses à l'excution de posco vide
parce que je crois qu'il faut des
réponses à des à des questions qui
étaient bien lente et à qui était
antérieure à la situation qu vide
merci chers collègues alors nous devons
siéger dans l'hémicycle à 15 heures pour
les questions d'actualité donc il nous
reste un quart d'heure
20 minutes environ est ce que vous
auriez d'autres d'autres questions oui
allez-y merci une dernière question vous
l'avez noté au début la présence ici de
nombreux sénateurs voire de la totalité
de la mission d'information
preuve de leur implication jusqu'au bout
de cette mission vous avez également
parlé d'un consensus sur le rapport et
d'une adoption à l'unanimité
est ce que c'est quelque chose de rare
est-ce que c'est lié au sujet de la vie
étudiante est précisément et est-ce un
signe positif pour un portage politique
plus important des recommandations par
la suite merci merci et ce qu'il y
aurait d'autres
d'autres questions prises prise de
parole oui sur le système de bourses est
ce que le reste à charge prend enfin
est-ce que la bourse décentraliser le
terme aidants et dans votre document
c'est ce serait aussi prendre en compte
le coût du logement dans la région et
adapter les aides
d'accord c'était juste merci monsieur le
rapporteur
pour répondre à votre première question
sur le consensus bon c'est pas c'est pas
exceptionnel au sénat d'avoir un
consensus mais c'est loin d'être
systématique et on pouvait imaginer que
sur un sujet comme ça qui est un sujet
un peu sensible actuellement
que ce consensus ne se dégage pas si
facilement je dois avouer que le
président insiste là-dessus mais il a
raison tout au long des auditions étape
a récapitulé mais on a fait de
nombreuses tables rondes ont auditionné
de 2,2 de nombreux intervenants dans la
diversité des secteurs concernés par
cette cette mission très honnêtement à
la fois sur le diagnostic et sur les
propositions ce consensus s'est fait
j'allais dire naturellement et c'est
tant mieux
et évidemment vous avez raison de le
souligner pour la suite c'est important
parce que comme le disait fort juste
discrétion ronan sarrazy ce qui est
important c'est quand on sera sorti de
la crise du coc vide que les difficultés
des étudiants qui ont été mises en sur
la place publique si on peut dire ça
comme ça
il ya une prise de conscience collective
des difficultés avec le co vide surtout
que les politiques publiques suivent au
delà de la période de deux crises
sanitaires et c'est là où évidemment
nous aurons besoin de d'intervenir tout
ou tous ensemble qu'il y ait une
dimension législative ou non une
dimension budgétaire ou non à travers la
loi de finances rectificative en en
particulier sur la prise en compte du
coût du logement oui bien sûr c'est pour
ça
cette notion de reste à charge dans les
postes de dépenses principaux
il ya le coût du logement et si vous
êtes si vous avez un loyer de 200 euros
c'est évidemment pas du tout la même
chose que si vous en avez 1 600 600
euros de l'impact en termes de pouvoir
d'achat et de ce qui reste à la fin du
mois donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
assiste sur cette notion de reste à
charge parce que le coût du logement est
un élément très différenciant sur la
situation financière des étudiants de
même il faut bien le reconnaître aussi
que le soutien de la famille est un
élément aussi très différente est ce que
oui sur sur le le reste à charge
le sénat a fait réaliser par en interne
par un service ici une analyse
comparative des différents systèmes de
soutien la vie étudiante dans le monde
et en europe et par exemple dans le dans
le système allemand de distribution des
bourses le reste à charge est quelque
chose qui est parfaitement intégrée qui
est qui et qui permet d'ajuster en
fonction de la situation des territoires
le montant de la bourse donc ce n'est
pas une utopie c'est des choses qui se
pratique déjà déjà ailleurs sur le
logement étudiant mais j'aimerais vous
faire part de mon expérience de de
sénateur des hauts-de-seine où ou dans
deux villes qui sont d'ailleurs de
couleurs politiques différentes
sow avec son maire philippe laurent et
puis nanterre avec son maire patrick
jarry ce sont deux villes universitaires
où le maire ou les deux maires ont une
forte appétence pour le logement social
et ce qu'ils souhaiteraient pour le
logement étudiant évidemment qui est un
logement social
ce qu'ils souhaiteraient c'est que le
logement étudiant soit un élément de la
construction de la ville avec les
universités il estime notamment à
nanterre que
le grand campus avec des barres de
logement étudiant c'est sans doute
quelque chose qu'il faut dépasser qu'a
rendu un service indéniable mais qu'il
faut dépasser aujourd'hui et ce qu'ils
souhaitent eux c'est plutôt
l'installation dans des quartiers là où
ils ont la maîtrise du foncier de
petites unités de logements qui
permettent de ranimer des quartiers
d'intégrer aussi les étudiants à la vie
sociale pour créer une interaction forte
donc il souhaiterait être associés aux
politiques nationales du logement parce
que pour eux c'est un instrument fort de
leur vision urbanistique de leur ville
et ça c'est des choses qu'on doit
absolument permettre le le plan
gouvernemental qui est on l'a dit pas
une grande réussite n'avait pas cette
vision territoriale
on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'elle est
devenue absolument essentiel notamment
après la crise parce que là où les
étudiants ont le mieux résisté à la
crise c'est là où ils étaient intégrés
dans un tissu social très fort qui a pu
les prendre en charge
la grosse difficulté c'est les étudiants
qui ont eu beaucoup de mal à continuer à
vivre leurs relations sociales dans
leurs grands campus c'était sur le le
point je voulais ajouter par rapport au
logement
sincèrement je pense que c'est quelque
chose de deux capitales on est en train
tout doucement de repenser la relation
de l'université à la ville aux
territoires et aux collectivités et je
crois que c'est un élément majeur de
cette mission sur un porteur prolonger
la réflexion parce qu'elle est
effectivement très importante
l'a reçu à deux reprises l'association
des villes universitaires associations
en tant que tel et des villes membres et
ils nous ont souligné aussi que les les
universités les lieux dans les
universités que ce soit dans les amphis
ou pouvait servir comme des lieux de vie
pour l'ensemble de l'activité municipale
on peut très bien organiser ce qui est
le cas d'ailleurs dans un certain nombre
d'endroits des concerts dans dans un
amphi des concerts qui ne soit pas
réservée exclusivement aux étudiants
mais qui rentre dans le cadre d'une
politique municipale d'une spectacle
vivant donc l'interaction entre le lieu
d'enseignement universitaire et et la
ville il peut être très marquée très
forts à travers la logement comme dit
président mais aussi dans les différents
sites et culturelles sportives est ce
qui est est ce que vous avez encore
d'autres d'autres questions où on peut
s'en tenir provisoirement la avant de
futurs épisodes sur la vie étudiante
organisée par le sénat bon ben écoutez
je je propose de clôturer cette
conférence de presse en vous remerciant
vivement pour votre participation
[Musique]